I do think it's important not to leave
this discussion thinking that that the
sort of set them do coming from Dan is
the neuroscience the neuro scientific
arguments against fail because they're
philosophically naive and free wills
really important politically and
culturally therefore we should be
compatible right in if there's this
other big piece in there dan has a
theory of the conscious volitional human
being right and which is designed among
other things to be a sort of explanation
sketch for how evolution produced it and
how it computes that how its brain
produces its mind and how its brain in
interaction with the environment
produces meaningful self narratives and
produces selves of the kind that can be
authors of their own activity so all
that stuff's really quite important to
write if we had no story like that it
would be much more worried what else
would you want to make but but more
seriously
there are ways your brain could make you
do it and then there are other ways your
brain could make you do it and the trick
is which kind of way is it the
intermediate theory that Don is talking
about is the one which takes on that
challenge and says if this is how your
brain makes you do it you're responsible
that you're morally competent individual
those that's what we all want to be true
of ourselves and guess what folks it's
possible if we can be wired right their
brain made you do it in some other way
that you're wired wrong and then you
want it response well I don't think
there's different ways your brain makes
you I mean maybe this is radical but it
substantively I don't think there's any
difference between somebody killing
somebody or being a peter foe because
there
brain tumor or somebody killing somebody
because they were beaten up as a kid
which affected their neurons in such a
way that they had no choice but to be an
angry and go out and kill somebody and
otherwise seamlessly well and it's also
with also with the person who who
decides to commit a crime and then
commits a murder to cover the crime when
he just simply thought he could get away
with it you don't think there's any
difference with that brain I don't I
have encountered that off his argument
that for all effective purposes there is
no there's no substantive distinction
between somebody committing murder
because of the brain tumor and something
being somebody committing murder because
you know you wanted your capture or
whatever it is right but that right
right of course there's a there's a
causal story to be told there but again
um it seems to me first to choose two
things first of all if you take
seriously the idea that the human brain
is a organ to make decisions then the
situations actually are different there
are different inputs into the brain
there are different circumstances the
brain elaborates that that information
differently and in one case there's more
constraints imposed of the tumor there
is more constraints imposed in their
brain brain is malfunctioning and so one
of the things that I really am puzzled
often by by that that brain tumor
argument is that the brain tumor is
clearly a case where I think most of us
would agree the brain is not working
properly it's it's wired up wrong and so
that that case cannot possibly be
representative I think of a general way
well so that's an interesting one so I
was just thinking when you mentioned
that so the case of a childhood trauma
and making stuff as I go in a moment but
but surely some neurobiologist could
could back this up that one might be
intermediate there might be a situation
where the the constraints impulse in
your brain are going to be less than the
tumor but but more than a normal person
who grew up with
we all have causes for what we do I mean
my view is the first is yes but there is
a curve there's a there is a bell curve
or your tumor is over here and you know
you're incredibly good education
nurturing environment everything is
going out is well is over there and then
there's the rest of us
you